dans l'actualité ce soir la birmanie
entrouvre la porte à l'aide humanitaire
les états unis veulent accélérer et
envisage de largages de vivres de tentes
aux sinistrés avec ou sans
l'autorisation du régime faut-il
redouter une nouvelle guerre civile au
liban des combats ont éclaté dans
plusieurs quartiers de beyrouth le
hezbollah accuse le gouvernement
pro-occidental de lui avoir déclaré la
guerre les célébrations de la victoire
alliée du 8 mai l ont pas eu lieu sur
les champs elysées et sur les plages de
normandie nicolas sarkozy a rendu
hommage au soldat du débarquement
la consommation de cigarettes s'effondre
en france après l'interdiction de fumer
dans tous les lieux publics une chute de
10% au mois de mars par rapport à l'an
passé un succès pour interpol le
pédophile présumé recherché via internet
a été arrêté aux états unis l'homme de
59 ans a reconnu les faits enfin la
foire de paris on verra que la fièvre de
la maison et de la décoration fait
naître un nouveau métier le consultant
déco est clair une ou deux heures de
conseil pour trouver des idées bonsoir
et bienvenue à tous avant de développer
ses titres des nouvelles de la torche
olympique loin des troubles qui ont
marqué son parcours la flamme a été
porté en haut de l'everest le sommet du
monde un symbole et un exploit sportif
aussi à pékin samah soula tristan le
braz
tôt ce matin dans l'himalaya ces
alpinistes portait la flamme olympique
mais aussi tous les espoirs de la chine
de briller aux yeux du monde
quoi de plus symbolique sont plus hauts
sommets ce nouveau défi aux lois de la
nature
aucune combustion n'est naturel à une
telle altitude
les chiens ont conçu une torche spéciale
avec différents mélanges gazeux et
apport d'oxygène allumé 40 mètres avant
le sommet par moins 30 degrés la corde
et de 10,9 alpinistes chinois des
tibétains est parti à l'assaut de
l'everest
sur le camp de base à 8300 mètres
d'altitude un incroyable déploiement
médiatique la télévision départ
retransmet l'événement en direct les
images sont censés faire oublier au
monde le relais chaotique de l'autre
flammes c'est une tibétaine qui porte la
flamme au sommet
8848 m drapeau chinoise et un olympiques
sont déployés vive les jeux olympiques
2008 longue vie au tibet longue vie à la
chine
shashi 2 luv lance la première de cordée
cela veut dire bonheur en tibétain au
quartier général l'équipe laisse
exploser sa joie
dix jours que la pression est intense
des conditions météos mettait en péril
l'ascension en direct le porte-parole de
la mission craque le chef de
l'expédition lui que
nous avions promis au monde de réussir
c'est un rêve de plusieurs années qui se
réalise enfin
aucun incident pro tibétains est venue
perturber la photo de l'exploit il faut
dire que les autorités chinoises avaient
interdit tout accès à cette zone depuis
des semaines oui des larmes de joie côté
chinois mais protestations de l'autre
côté de la frontière côté tibétain en
est pâle malgré l'interdiction une
nouvelle manifestation était organisée
est durement réprimée à noter
parallèlement que le dialogue est renoué
le gouvernement tibétain en exil dirigé
par le dalaï lama annonce que des
négociations officielles vont reprendre
avec la chine suite aux entretiens
informels de ces derniers jours la
situation en birmanie à chaque jour son
nouveau chiffre à l'onu a estimé
aujourd'hui qu'un million un million de
personnes ont besoin d' aide à premier
avion des nations unies s'est posé à
rangoon mais c'est une exception les
généraux refusent toujours d'ouvrir les
portes en grand arnaud bouteille
dans certains quartiers de rangoon seuls
les murs tiennent encore debout personne
même en ville ne semble avoir été
épargné six jours après le passage du
cyclone tout reste à dégager
reconstruire avec des moyens de fortune
dans le delta dévasté plusieurs villages
n'existe plus autour des temples détruit
les rares maisons se transforme en
refuge pour ces bouches à nourrir
le temps presse
notre maison est détruite complètement
détruite
nous avons de quoi manger ce matin me
n'y a plus rien pour ce soir
à la butte à l'une des communes les plus
touchées les survivants regrouper et
désemparé pleurent leurs disparus dans
ce pays fermé quelques témoignages
parviennent à contourner la censure
que les secours sont arrivés ici non en
personne n'est venu
les gens aux freins j'ai entendu qu'on
allait distribuer du riz alors nous
sommes venus que nous a dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de rythme
le journaliste vide alors ses poches des
médicaments et quelques billets
les images contraste avec la propagande
à la télévision les militaires
distribuer vive et nourriture les
généraux visite les écoles et les
hôpitaux on estime à 100 mille le nombre
de morts mais l'aide se fait rare et la
frontière reste fermé et 26 millions
d'euros dead c'est la somme promise par
la communauté internationale
gouvernements et associations mais les
vivres et les tentes s'entassent aux
frontières notamment en thaïlande c'est
là bas que nous retrouvons nos envoyés
spéciaux loïc de la mornais et bruno
carette
c'est la douzième fois que pierre
fouillant et qui les nerfs se rendre à
l'ambassade de birmanie ces deux
responsables humanitaires n'ont pas pu
déposer de demande de visa hier alors ce
matin il espère que les fonctionnaires
de l'ambassade seront un peu plus
compréhensifs verdict à la sortie nouvel
échec se démarquer le fort a priori
d'empathie du gouvernement pour port
pour sa population il ya aucune forme
d'un truisme c'est absolument choquant
traître jour au même moment dans les
locaux de la croix rouges thaïlandaises
des bénévoles charge l'un des tout
premiers envois humanitaire des sacs
pour plusieurs centaines de familles
autant dire une goutte d'eau face au
million de sans abri pire mans chaque
colis se compose de nourriture de
bougies de kits d'hygiène de toiles de
tentes et de pastilles de purification
d'eau
la thaïlande a connu le tsunami de 2004
et nous savons très bien ce dont les
gens ont besoin en cas d'inondation de
désastre
le mode est en voie de la croix rouge
est embarqué dans cet avion de l'armée
de l'air thaïlandaise la birmanie a
exigé des thaïlandais qu'aucun
occidental ne survole le territoire
birman ce sera le seul vol de la journée
depuis bangkok des millions de personnes
l'attendent
l'ambassade de birmanie le délivrera
encore aucun visa ni aujourd'hui ni
demain ces fonctionnaires semblent plus
concernés par l'organisation d'un
référendum soit disant démocratique ce
week end et que la gente militaire a
maintenu malgré des millions de
personnes sans abri aujourd'hui le sud
de la birmanie semble bel et bien
sacrifier au nom d'une certaine vision
de la raison d'état le blocage donc mais
ce soir je vous le disais en titre les
états unis haussent le ton ce régime est
paranoïaque a déclaré la représentante
de washington en birmanie pour accélérer
les choses la maison blanche envisage
maintenant de larguer des vivres avec ou
sans autorisation bonsoir l'un de
chalvron vous êtes à washington c'est
vraiment une idée sérieuse
ah oui je pense que c'est sérieux parce
que tout simplement on commence à en
avoir ras-le-bol et puis vous savez tout
est prêt ici on a débloqué de l'argent
on a des avions sur place d'hélicoptères
des bateaux étaient déroutés des
milliers de colis sont prêts et toujours
pas de réponse laura bush est monté au
créneau george bush le président
condoleezza rice pour supplier la junte
d'ouvrir les portes pas de réponse le
sénat ça c'est assez rare le sénat a
voté une résolution dans ce sens là et
toujours toujours toujours pas de
réponse alors tout est prêt sur place
pour le moment on on essaye encore
d'obtenir un feu vert de la part des
autorités birmanes mais on ne cache pas
que oui s'il n'y a pas de feu vert et
bien on s'en passera tout simplement la
décision n'est pas encore prise mais je
crois qu'effectivement c'est tout à fait
sérieux merci alain on reste à
l'étranger avec le liban hier nous vous
décrivions un pays en état de paralysie
et sous forte tension et bien
aujourd'hui un pas de plus est franchi
vers la guerre civile ce ne sont plus
des incidents mais bel et bien des
combats qui ont éclaté à beyrouth entre
le hezbollah et le gouvernement pro
occidental
gérard griesbeck
beyrouth semble avoir repris le chemin
de la guerre civile cet après midi les
rues quasi désertes de la capitale
étaient livrés aux 1000 x les sunnites
qui soutiennent le gouvernement contre
les chiites du hezbollah
et au milieu des combats l'armée
libanaise impuissante à affirmer son
autorité alors que depuis des mois le
pays n'a toujours pas de président de la
république
en vidéoconférence pour des raisons de
sécurité le chef du hezbollah s'est
déclarée en guerre contre le
gouvernement libanais hassan nasrallah a
accusé ce même gouvernement d'être à la
botte des américains et d'israël
son mouvement a coupé la route de
l'aéroport le trafic aérien est presque
paralysée la crise a démarré il ya 48
heures à la suite du limogeage du
responsable de la sécurité accusée d'
espionnage au profit du hezbollah ce
soir le chef de la majorité saad hariri
a appelé hassan nasrallah à mettre fin
au siège de beyrouth il n'est pas sûr
que cela fasse baisser la tension
une information encore à l'étranger
silvio berlusconi a présenté son
gouvernement ait prêté serment en italie
en un temps record il se dit pressé de
gouverner pour faire face à la crise
l'équipe compte 21 ministres dont quatre
femmes elle est nettement orienté à
droite puisqu'elle intègre quatre
représentants de la ligue du nord parti
europhobe et anti immigrés qui obtient
notamment le ministère de l'intérieur
umberto bossi son président fait
lui-même son entrée dans ce gouvernement
en france les célébrations de la
victoire alliée du 8 mai qui a marqué la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale elles
n'ont pas eu lieu sur les champs elysées
comme c'est l usage mais sur les plages
du débarquement en normandie nicolas
sarkozy a voulu rendre hommage aux
soldats qui ont participé à l'opération
et notamment aux français du commando
kaefer michaël darmon vivien roussel sur
place
nicolas sarkozy revisite une plage de
l'histoire à ouistreham en normandie les
fusilliers marins français du commando
qui faire se sont battus aux côtés des
quinze mille soldats canadiens débarqué
ici le 6 juin 1944
un an plus tard le 8 mai 1945 la
deuxième guerre mondiale est terminée
nous ne célébrons pas seulement une
victoire militaire nous célébrons avant
tout une victoire morale le chef de
l'état veut renouveler le style de ces
cérémonies ces événements seront bientôt
santé - et doivent pour lui de venir
chaque année des tableaux de l'histoire
nationale et à propos de la
collaboration il s'inscrit dans la
lignée du général de gaulle et de
françois mitterrand vichy dit il n'était
pas la france
aucune faute
aucun crime ne doit être oublié
la vraie france
n'était pas à vichy qu'elle n'était pas
dans la collaboration la vraie france
elle n'était pas dans la milice la vraie
france
la france éternelle
et la paix la fois du général de gaulle
hasard du calendrier cette date du 8 mai
s'inscrit dans le prolongement de
l'anniversaire de l'élection de nicolas
sarkozy à l'elysée l'occasion pour le
chef de l'état de prendre de la hauteur
par rapport aux aléas de la vie
politique et pour les plus jeunes
d'entre nous il faut rappeler que 177
français composé le commando qui faire
comment at il été constitué qui étaient
ses soldats reportage nicolas
lemarignier sébastien laffargue
20 ans à peine du courage à revendre ce
sont les hommes du commando kieffer les
premiers à avoir débarqué sur les plages
de normandie le 6 juin 44
à leur tête philippe kieffer à 40 ans
passés ce directeur de banque installée
à new york décide de rejoindre de gaulle
à londres en mai 1941 il crée le premier
commando français de fusiliers marins
une vingtaine d'hommes au départ sont 77
en 1944 léon gautier était l'un de 60
ans après le dévouement est intacte kiev
était un homme faut pas oublier à faut
pas oublier c'est grâce à lui que nous
aurons eu le privilège d'être la saison
à 44 c'est ici au redoutable centre
d'entraînement dac macquarie en écosse
aux côtés des commandos britanniques que
les hommes de qit fer s'entraînent en
vue du débarquement leur bravoure
impressionne les anglais alors au matin
du 6 juin 1944 ce son qui faire et ses
soldats qui sont les premiers à poser le
pied sur les plages normandes
et voilà il n'a pas beaucoup d'entre
vous deviendront
celui qui ne veut pas partir il peut
sortir des rangs gens voudraient pas
personne n'est sorti des rangs sont tous
très solidaires
l'objectif militaire les points
fortifiée du littoral et le casino de
ouistreham un véritable camp retranché
nazis à 9h30 avec l'aide d'un char
américain qui faire et ses hommes
reprennent le casino les habitants de
ouistreham surpris découvre qu'il ya des
français parmi leurs libérateurs
au soir du 6 juin 41 hommes ont été tués
ou blessés les héros du commando kieffer
viennent d'entrer dans la légende de la
seconde guerre mondiale
et auparavant dans la matinée nicolas
sarkozy avait déposé une gerbe au pied
de la statue du général de gaulle au bas
des champs elysées à paris au son du
chant des partisans et de la
marseillaise
une information importante est
encourageante en matière de santé
publique l'interdiction de fumer dans
tous les lieux publics depuis le début
de l'année a des conséquences directes
la consommation de cigarettes a chuté de
10% en volume c'est ce qu'indiquent les
chiffres du mois de mai de mars par don
hahn guéri eric de l'agneau
dans le monde de la brasserie évidemment
rien n'est plus comme avant même en
terrasse désormais les volutes de
cigarettes se font discrètes sans doute
l'une des conséquences de l'interdiction
de fumer dans les bars et restaurants
certains en ont vraiment profité pour
arrêter parole d'une ex fumeuse qui a
grillé son dernier mégot le 4 janvier
c'est tout ça sur les bars je ne fume
plus du tout et raconte grâce à ceux qui
comprennent quel vieux et ben je peux
aller prendre tranquillement que ann hui
l heure les endroits sans avoir l ce
côté étouffant des cigarettes quant aux
irréductibles ils ont diablement réduit
leur consommation
c'est vrai que là on a beaucoup diminué
moi je pense à moi que j'ai vu que très
rarement la leur il ya déjà trois
cigarettes dans la quart d'heure c'est
de combien pour on
va dire de l'inde à cinq par jour
du coup en mars 2008 la vente de
cigarettes s'est effondré de 10 % mais à
cette chute selon ce buraliste il y
aurait tout de même une autre
explication les gens se présentent avec
des cartouches viennent de l'étranger
qui viennent de partout on les paye
trois femmes cherchent à paris
et maintenant il les montre
si on mars 2008 malgré un marché en
baisse on a encore vendu près de 15
milliards de cigarettes et autres
cigarillos ce alors question maintenant
faut-il aller plus loin encore dans la
prévention contre le tabac d image
repoussante pourraient bientôt
apparaître sur les paquets de cigarettes
c'est ce que préconise un rapport remis
à l'institut national du cancer neuf
pays dans le monde applique déjà cette
recette florence bouquet à patrick
johnston
ce sont des poumons à droite des poumons
de fumeur lui c'est un malade sous
assistance respiratoire jusqu'à la fin
de sa vie ce jeune enfant dommage pour
lui à des parents à croix aux cigarettes
or les fumeurs meurent prématurément
ces images chocs bientôt sur les paquets
de cigarettes en france existe déjà sur
les cigarettes belge pas de quoi
décourager les fumeurs français qui
achètent leurs cartouches moins cher en
belgique si bon maya un petit quand même
un petit côté écoeurant quoi donc si
rexie éventuellement il ya une cartouche
avec une autre photo peut-être y en a
qui se permettront de me dire je
préférerais leurs cartouches ne bon le
général committee l'on retourne le
paquet
pour la gauche du coup d'acheter moins
car plus non
ouais mais oui oui je sais oui vous
savez je connais des gens je connais des
gens qui fument pas du tout elles qui
sont mortes du cancer
pourtant selon ce chercheur ces visuels
chocs peuvent avoir un véritable essai
et pas seulement sur les fumeurs
c'est un outil qui est intéressant pour
rappel la des normalisations du
tabagisme et du tabac c'est à dire pour
donner une mauvaise image aux au
tabagisme d'autres pays européens vont
très bientôt rendre les avertissements
choc obligatoires sur les paquets de
cigarettes la lutte contre le tabagisme
n'est pas terminée un succès pour
interpol nous vous parlions en début de
semaine de ce pédophile présumé
recherché par la police internationale
un avis de recherche avait été diffusé
pour la deuxième fois via internet est
bien l'homme a été arrêté aux états unis
il a semble-t-il reconnu les faits
pierre monéger thierry simonet il était
recherché depuis deux ans il aura fallu
moins de deux jours pour arrêter cet
homme après la diffusion de sa photo
wenn nelson corliss un comédien
américain de 59 ans a été interpellé la
nuit dernière à son domicile d'union
city dans le new jersey il a très vite
avoué avoir abusé d'enfants de 6 à 10
ans trois étudiants ont reconnu son
visage sur l'avis de recherche
international lancé par interpol on a
déçu beaucoup des contacts
à peupler on peut dire sous les 500
aussi email en particulier des étudiants
de cette faculté
des droits aux états unis où il on a
reconnu la personne qui avait fait un
stage qui avait travaillé dans nuit dans
cette université les policiers affirment
disposer d'une centaine de photos
pornographiques de cet homme en
compagnie d'enfants asiatiques c'est la
deuxième fois qu'interpol fait appel au
public pour neutraliser un pédophile
présumé en octobre dernier christopher
paul nil un canadien de 32 ans était
arrêté en thaïlande dix jours après la
diffusion de sa photo alors qu'il était
recherché en vain depuis quatre ans il
est aujourd'hui en prison à bangkok dans
la tente de son procès
oubliez le présent célébrant l'histoire
et quelle histoire ce pourrait être la
devise des israéliens qui s'élèverait
aujourd'hui le 60e anniversaire de la
naissance de l'état hébreu en 1948
soixante ans de succès militaire de
consolidation démographique est aussi la
réussite économique les nombreuses
cérémonies en doc occulter un instant la
crise politique qui menaçait ou d'olmert
tu es aussi le dialogue avec les
palestiniens qui n'avance pas témoin de
cette société israélienne très diverse
voici l'exemple d'un groupe de médecins
depuis des années ils bravent les
barrages militaires et les préjugés pour
tendre la main aux palestiniens les
médecins de l'impossible c'est le
dossier de cette édition il est signé
charles enderlin khaled abou aker
les consultations médicales en pleine
nuit
près de naples aux médecins de renom le
professeur raphi baldhead examine la
jambe de saïd un patient palestiniens
le problème c'est qu'il n'a pas eu accès
à un médecin un spécial et
jusqu'aujourd'hui parce que dans ce
village isolé il ne peut pas
traverser les barrages pour arriver à
limite de naplouse veut pas traverser le
barrage pour rêver dans un hôpital
israélien nous faisons cette clinique
improvisée au bord de la route
spécialiste de chirurgie vasculaire rafi
valdan préside l'association israélienne
des médecins pour les droits de l'homme
ce sont des volontaires juifs et arabes
qui le week end vont en cisjordanie
soigner les malades palestiniens
aujourd'hui à bellagio un village isolé
300 patients les attendent
nous sommes venus exprimer notre
solidarité avec le peuple palestinien et
son combat
et vous montrer un autre visage de la
société israélienne
n'est pas que la police ait laissé
droite
une pharmacie improvisé est installé
dans le couloir
ici sont réalisées des opérations de
petite chirurgie là un spécialiste
examine les cas de diabète
le pédiatre lui est très demandée
achmed 17 ans est un cas particulier
gravement malade il a eu la chance de
recevoir une transplantation cardiaque
il y a cinq ans en italie
depuis de retour dans son village il n'a
pas le suivi médical indispensable et
souffre des effets secondaires du
traitement anti rejet pour l'amener en
consultation dans un hôpital israël je
suis chez un cardiologue qui suit nos
patients après transplantation cardiaque
alors on va profiter aussi de la bonne
volonté de noir membres de notre
organisation pour le voir gratuitement
lava et deux semaines plus tard ahmed et
son père sont autorisés à franchir les
barrages militaires
ils se rendent près de tel-aviv à
l'hôpital tel hashomer
gabon israélien qui traite humainement
les palestiniens mais d'autres veulent
nous faire partir c'est quand même un
exemple et pour lui pour cet enfant pour
pour sa famille pour ses proches c'est
comme une petite lueur au fond au bout
du tunnel se disent que tous les items
sont pas forcément méchant armes et de
regagner son village il espère recevoir
l'autorisation de revenir dans six mois
de nouveaux examens
charles enderlin qui vient de publier
par le feu et par le sang le combat
clandestin pour l'indépendance d'israël
de 1936 à 48 aux éditions albin michel
en bref la course folle du pétrole tous
les superlatifs ont été épuisés le prix
du baril a frôlé hier soir à new york
les 124 dollars 123 90 exactement depuis
des années des ingénieurs travaillent
sur des sources d'énergie alternatives
voici la première usine destinée à
exploiter commercialement le courant
sous-marin provoquée par les marées elle
produira de l'électricité pour un
millier de foyers dès cet été en irlande
reportage maryse burgot laurent des bois
ces ingénieurs britanniques présente
avec fierté leur bébé une sorte de moule
incapable de transformer l'énergie des
courants en électricité et dans ce
magnifique bras de mer de l'irlande du
nord ils ont réussi à se mettre la
population dans la poche
c'est une énergie propre donc forcément
une bonne chose
une énergie stupéfiante dans ce détroit
où les courants atteignent 8 noeuds pour
l'instant les travaux ne sont pas
terminés d'où la présence de cette barge
mais à l'avenir ces fermes de moulins
seront construites en pleine mer et
l'essentiel se passera sous l'eau quand
ses hélices de 16 mètres d'envergure
capteront cet inépuisable mouvement des
océans
nous avons cette ressource disponible et
nous avons des kilomètres de côtes
je crois que notre dépendance importante
à l'égard du pétrole nous oblige à faire
quelque chose
en août prochain ce petit port de 2000
âmes vivra donc une première mondiale
l'hydrolienne sera fin prête raccordé au
réseau électrique national
elle alimentera mille maisons de quoi
faire la fierté des habitants même si
cet engin gâche un peu le paysage y
compris les jours de brouillard
j'espère qu'à l'avenir les designers les
rendre un peu plus joli tout mais ce
n'est pas très grave je pense qu'on
s'habitue rentrer
reste une question quel sera l'impact
sur l'environnement de ces hydroliennes
installé à grande échelle vont elles
perturbé les écosystèmes où les espèces
animales c'est paisible phoques se
blesseront t-il avec les hélices pas de
réponse pour l'instant même si l'on sait
qu'il n'existe pas d'énergie parfaite la
grande bretagne est une île le pays se
voit donc déjà comme une sorte d'arabie
saoudite de l'énergie marine les
britanniques pour d'ailleurs les
premiers à investir autant d'argent dans
ce genre d'installation oui en france un
prototype de turbines sous marines a
également été installé en bretagne à
bénodet mais il s'agit pour l'instant
d'un modèle expérimental on en avait
parlé ici-même en bref toujours à propos
d'environnement on reparle de la
cohabitation difficile entre l'homme et
l'ours dans les pyrénées à bagnères de
luchon une nouvelle attaque a été
constaté contre des brebis la plus
importante depuis le début de la saison
puisque sept moutons sont morts des
tests adn en cours devrait confirmer
qu'il s'agit de la femelle slovène va la
réintégrer dans la région il y a deux
ans
des images maintenant pour tous ceux qui
ont travaillé ou qui n'ont pas pu
profiter de ce 8 mai voici un peu de
soleil par procuration images de paris
d'abord signé david frossard avec des
bousculades dans les fontaines publiques
desjardins il a fait 27 degrés la france
avec lui un peu partout une journée
d'été et pas seulement au bord de la mer
exemple à lyon marie laure guerrier
roulant eric chacun
que d'eau que d'eau mais cette fois on
en redemande fini la pluie place aux
grands votants 28 degrés dans le centre
ville de lyon petite tenue de
circonstance et pique nique improvisé
sur le trottoir on s'entraînait dans un
club de vente d'un côté et donc
on avait envie de voir le jour et on est
très content d'être là au départ c'était
pas prévu très réjouissant que mon été à
la danse mais on profite du soleil en
même temps parfait et les cheveux nous
faire danser dehors c'est une voyante
d'autres ont eu tout le loisir de
peaufiner le programme un déjeuner sur
l'herbe c'est quand même mieux c'est
vraiment sympa la dois profiter du
soleil un petit peu là en plus on fait
de pont donc on en profite c'est sympa
on va aller se balader un petit peu le
le long des berges des berges de l'autre
côté du rhône totalement prise d'assaut
par les cyclistes et les baigneurs
bonjour les pieds
super tout le monde est content et elle
est également peu la leçon là y'a pas de
problème
est ce qu'on peut rêver mieux un bon
bouquin les pieds dans l'eau
et le bonheur va durer à lyon au moins
jusqu'à lundi
cela ne vous a sans doute pas échappé en
ce mois de mai 2008 au commémore où on
célèbre selon les points de vue le 40e
anniversaire des événements de mai 68 on
a déjà tout nu ou tout dit sur les
conséquences politiques et sociales mais
qu'en est il pour l'émancipation
féminine en fait 68 a été davantage un
accélérateur qu'autre chose l'évolution
était bien entamée et les femmes
n'étaient pas si nombreux sur les
barricades josé blanc la pierre alexis
delcourt
dim dam dom une fois par mois le
dimanche
honneur aux femmes
la télé est encore en noir et blanc la
pilule il ya tout juste d'exister
on approche de 68 les femmes montrent
leurs genoux pour la première fois
les vieilles femmes s'en sont gentils ça
les a vus mamelles va prouve par contre
les femmes de 40 à 50 ans on sent très
méchant grossière
dans un environnement très jalouse
elle ose et commencent à donner leurs
avis certaines trop décontracté se font
licencier par le rtf
pour avoir montré ses genoux
représentante et les dimanches noëlle
noblecourt sera congédié
et aline bock quand les stars se confie
à denise glaser elle montre une image de
petite fille soumise je ne peux pas me
tuer comment ça c'est pas c'est toujours
assez impressionnant de faire un
interview oui puis parler de soi c'est
un cg non celle qu'ils ne se gênent pas
en revanche c'est elle une femme libre
qui édite un livre qu aucun censuré
pour un livre érotique
très gentiment érotique à côté de ce qui
est plus elle peut être publiés par la
suite on me saisissent l'olive donc moi
je ne comprends pas et je proclame haut
et fort que je suis pour que ce que l'
obscénité elle n'est pas dans les livres
que je publie mais les dans les une de
france soir là dans l'une de l'image et
dans les une de tous les journaux de
l'époque à propos de la guerre du
vietnam
progressivement le carcan de la mère au
foyer se fissure la femme enfin obtenu
d'ouvrir un compte en banque sans
l'accord de son mari elle prend goût à
l'indépendance mai 68 sera le
déclencheur
avortement libre et gratuit mariage
piège à cons
c'est au tour des femmes de descendre
dans la rue le mlf et créé dans la
foulée octobre au 18 nous avons compté
les premières réunions non mixtes nomix
parce qu'on avait remarqué que qui avait
3000 femmes dont une assemblée si un
seul homme c'était lui qui parlait voilà
personne nous éprouvons la parole
c'était comme ça après avoir obtenu la
pilule en 67 les femmes obtiennent le
droit à l'avortement 75
presque dix ans après
la foire de paris l'époque on sait à la
passion de la maison et des arts
ménagers pour les femmes comme pour les
hommes et bien un nouveau métier est en
train d'apparaître le consultant déco
est clair une ou deux heures de conseil
pour trouver des idées tout simplement
c'est bien sûr beaucoup moins cher qu'un
décorateur attitré nicolas lemarignier
samuel humaine
moderne coloré classique ou zen la déco
de la maison désormais ça intéresse tout
le monde alors les architectes
d'intérieur se sont mis à la portée du
grand public
ça peut être une peinture mais ça peut
être
la pierre c'est très très bon
preuve dans les allées de la foire de
paris où plan d'appartements main les
visiteurs peuvent demander des conseils
gratuits à des architectes d'intérieur
renommée que j'ai trouvée quand même
très intéressant le rencontrant c'est
que les idées que j'avais au départ
je pars avec des noëls
d'intérieur c'est le nouveau nom que se
donnent ces spécialistes comme celui-ci
direction boulogne pour voir le résultat
de son travail dans ce pavillon la
maîtresse des lieux a fait appel au
coach pour tout refaire du sol au
plafond on a commencé par du shopping
tous les deux à flâner à voir il m'a
présenté des produits on a regardé il a
sauvé les relais la vue si on se sentait
à l'aise avec ce type de produit pour
arriver à quelque chose de complètement
nouveau mais qui nous ressemblent aussi
les tarifs il se démocratise un peu on
peut faire appel à un coach à la mode
pendant une heure pour 130 euros les
clients de plus en plus de jeunes
ménages ils ont fait une sélection de
mobilier ils ont tous des idées sur les
couleurs a et donc on va rentrer hyper
cohérent passe deux heures ensemble et à
partir de la région comme des jeunes yp
elle n'est muré terrasse en pleine mode
de la déco les architectes d'intérieur
veulent leur part du gâteau en france en
moyenne chaque ménage dépense 754 euros
par an pour le bricolage et la
décoration
du cinéma avec un film d'action cette
semaine sur les écrans basées sur des
faits réels il retrace l'histoire du gal
le groupe antiterroriste de libération
créé dans les années 80 en espagne pour
répondre aux attentes à 2 t à avec les
dérives que l'on connaît c'est josé
garcia qui tient le premier rôle
marie-jo juin patrice brugère ce film
retrace l'histoire du gaz
une cellule de policiers créée en
espagne dans les années 80 leur objectif
assassiné clandestinement les
séparatistes basques de letea j'ai
travaillé pour légal tout ce que je
demande c'est qu'on les arrête avant
qu'il devienne incontrôlable le
personnage central du film existe il est
journaliste et a risqué sa vie en
dénonçant dans son journal les exactions
du gal encore aujourd'hui il se
déplaçait haute protection
il est commandant l'arrivée la halle
enquête a été difficile et complète
le gouvernement de monsieur
tout cela a été très dur mais le travail
de journaliste
vraiment gratifiant
même corps miralles également producteur
du film a tenu à le présenter au coeur
même du pays basse à saint-jean-de-luz
c'est josé garcia lui aussi d'origine
espagnole qui joue son rôle pas d'autres
questions
une dernière si vous permettez colonel
êtes-vous l'un des dirigeants du cal
traversait toujours la frontière et
cidre avec félicien je me souviens de
désinscription qu'ils avaient sur les
murs je voyais le théâtre assassins des
trucs des mouvements révolutionnaires
des trucs des fascistes ya toujours des
trucs et des choses tagués et puis avant
j'ai vu galles galles trois lettres qui
ont empoisonné l'histoire de l'espagne
des victimes innocentes et la mise en
cause de policiers corrompus de hauts
fonctionnaires comme le ministre de
l'intérieur jusqu'au chef du
gouvernement de l'époque felipe gonzalez
incarné ici par bernard le coq
devrait-il pas avoir quelque chose de
plus à me dire qu'en deux fonctionnaires
de police sont accusés terrorisme
dis-moi dix mots ministre n'avons eu
quoi que ce soit à voir avec le calme au
rythme haletant du thriller voilà
l'occasion de découvrir un pan méconnu
de l'histoire de l'espagne
une image de sport belle finale en
perspective dans la coupe de france
après le psg l'ont lyon s'est qualifié
hier soir face à sedan match en éclats
pour l'ol
un fait finalement la différence vous
l'avez vu avec un coup franc à 35 mètres
des buts signés jugnot finale lyon psg
donc à suivre sur france 2 ce sera le 24
mai prochain un salut de bienvenue à
deux nouveaux confrères dans les
kiosques sansfaçon revue mensuelle de
vie pratique et d'astuces et de conseils
et puis very l1 semestriels déclinaison
version luxe du célèbre magazine elle
avant de refermer ce journal je vous en
rappelle deux des principaux titres la
birmanie entrouvre la porte à l'aide
humanitaire mais elle n'en trouvera
seulement les états unis veulent
accélérer et envisage le largage de
vivre et de temps aux sinistrés avec ou
sans l'autorisation du régime et puis la
crainte d'une nouvelle guerre civile au
liban ce soir des combats ont éclaté
dans plusieurs quartiers de beyrouth
entre le hezbollah qui assiègent la
capitale et le gouvernement pro
occidental
il y a déjà au moins deux morts le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu lance un
appel au calme c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi tout de
suite la météo laurent romejko 20h50
envoyé spécial autour de guilaine chenu
et françoise joly avec notamment un
portrait de jean dujardin très bonne
soirée
l'info en continu cette audition
trousses de foi fr